welcome back to another edition of The
Gadget Lab podcast I'm Michel colori and
I'm John Phillips we've got a great show
for you this week we're gonna take a
look at the jawbone up we have a couple
of new phones that Christine is gonna
show us and we're gonna take a look back
in time at the Virtual Boy console first
John you have this personal
what is it necessary it's a band that
you put around your wrist and then it's
a pedometer inside so it could see it
can measure all the steps you take and
then during the middle of the night
it could measure how much you move which
can tell you the next day when you plug
the jawbone back into your iPhone it can
tell you how well you slept so it's like
a health monitoring device it's a health
monitor a lifestyle changing right so
this is not the first time you've shown
this to us right so this is the third
time we've had it on the gadget lab
podcast and this is also the third band
that I've had and I've had three bands
because jawbone the company that makes
it has needed to send me a new band
because the first two died on me and
this was really why we are bringing it
back for this this third time there
seems to be a pretty significant problem
with quality control as far as the
band's dying on consumers so there's 30
Amazon reviews right now it's getting a
2 out of 5 stars on Amazon I would say a
significant portion maybe twenty
twenty-five percent of the people are
complaining about their bands dying this
is my third dead band so you keep
calling them up saying this one died
send me another one yeah so I just got
off the phone literally about 15 minutes
ago with the founder of jawbone and they
are working diligently to find out
what's wrong with the bands and they
they think they're getting closer to a
fix he won't tell me the percentage that
all the bands that are affected but
clearly they are very frustrated that
something is amiss so this is this is a
pretty hot product this is like a very
sort of hotly anticipated holiday item
it's $100 which is a good price point
yeah and
been waiting for this all year which is
why you've probably heard about it I'm
wired a lot it's been Futurama wired a
lot it's also very hot category yeah so
there's a lot of action here and how
badly did job load and slip on the ice
on this one I think pretty badly uh you
know I've definitely tested products
that weren't ready for primetime but
when you see how many complaints there
are on Amazon this is my third band
there's extensive complaints on
Jawbone's forums and then other
journalists are experiencing what I've
experienced essentially it works for a
few days then you try to sync it in your
iPhone it doesn't sync and essentially
it just breaks mmm so you know I I would
have given it a really positive review
and the review is coming that should go
up soon but at this point I can't
recommend the product it when it works
it's it's pretty cool but it doesn't
work that's the problem so what did you
like about it wouldn't what it did work
well what I really liked well two things
it has three modes there's a sleep mode
and there's a daytime mode and then
there is this mode where you shoot your
the food that you eat and what I love is
its own app right you're right and it
could tell me it could tell me how well
I slept I love that and it tells me how
many steps I took each day love that
that's cool yeah so it's it's definitely
something that people who are interested
in sort of changing the lifestyle
getting more active keeping better track
of how well they're taking yeah their
bodies it's a it's like a lifestyle
provoker it makes you want to be more
active it makes you want to sleep better
so there's a cattle prod I thought I had
alcohol all of these things but anyway
enough about the up let's get down with
some new phones Cristina's gonna show us
some new offerings from HTC
hi my name is Christina Bonnington and
I'm here to show you some new HTC 4G
Android phones today today we've got the
HTC Amaze 4G and the HTC Rezound first
off they've got a few similarities they
both got 1.5 gigahertz processors 4.3
inch capacitive touch screens and an 8
megapixel camera on the back the HTC
Amaze 4G is the cheaper of the two
running $260 on contract with t-mobile
it's a little bit different from the HTC
Rezound and that it has a dedicated
camera shutter and video recording
button and it's buttons are also raised
off the surface of the device of it
software wise it's pretty similar the
HTC Rezound is pretty similar to the
Amaze for Jean but it's got a few extras
it's got built-in Beats Audio and it's
also got a more pixel packed screen so
you don't see any of those little dots
of pixels on the display Beats Audio is
a feature you can turn on or off when
you're listening to music on the phone
it really just adds a lot of especially
in the bass when you pair it with $100 I
beats in your headphones that come with
a phone it really sounds great
the HTC Rezound will running $300 on
contract with Verizon so which would I
go for they're both solid phones they
run Android Gingerbread
they've got powerful processors the
experience is smooth but out spring the
extra 40 bucks for the HTC Rezound for
me the audio was just so much better
than on any other phone I've ever
listened to the beats really makes music
come alive it sounds much fuller and
livelier in your ears and the camera is
also a bit better than on the HTC ma is
4G images were sharper it was just a
better photographic experience John what
is this mic this is a Virtual Boy so
this is a console I guess you could call
it came out in 1995
it's a Nintendo Virtual Boy and it's
going to appear in our next 9
an article titled nine gadgets that
prove you're a hardcore early adopter in
other words nine gadgets that prove you
probably bought something you shouldn't
have buy so let me guess you bought this
back in like 1995 I didn't I did not buy
it oh you didn't buy this this actually
is a Nintendo review unit
yeah well that was delivered to me they
never asked for it back right so you
fired up some collective soul and that
openness of a new coke review this
product right right right so it it's
it's Nintendo's stab at 3d gaming so
essentially I don't know if we're gonna
demo this or not but I'll just give it a
little shot you would turn it on and
turns it on and you stick your head up
like this and you can either opt in or
opt out to a little worn it to a little
request that asks do you want to stop
this every 30 seconds because some
people might experience seizures they go
more than 30 seconds it uses what's
called parallax barrier 3d technology
and also the thing that really was it's
sort of the the stuck the the knife into
the body and killed it for good was that
it only uses red LEDs so it's not color
and it's unlike any other kind of video
game experience from 1995 or even today
but you stick your head into it and you
have your controller here and it had a
really small software library I don't
know how many total but I think I think
even on the aftermarket you can't find
more than 12 games or so and if I
remember correctly all the games sucked
yeah they suck the one that's loaded now
is a pinball game and it's it's the only
one that I ever came close to enjoying
there was there was a Mario franchise
game there was a tennis game there was a
boxing game they all were really bad the
gameplay wasn't fun you got a neck you
know crick in your neck he's trying to
if you stuck your head in there for too
long you couldn't see that controller
even if you wanted to so more of a
torture device
then like an early console more of a
torture device but as a piece of
industrial design it's sort of tribute
it is very trippy looking well so when
this came out it was $180 and you'd get
them on eBay now for a round same price
right oh it's actually you know sort of
people are sort of fans of this thing I
guess well I never really liked it I
tried it a little bit and it wasn't that
fun it didn't give me a seizure though
right and it didn't give me a seizure
either but yeah I mean industrial design
it's it says something I'm not sure what
it says it says Johnny Five is alive
yeah anyway we'll be back next week with
some more exciting stuff probably some
holiday themed items to show you on the
gadget lab podcast until then